For the first time in two decades
This is truly fascinating.
We are learning about
what happened
during a private Oval Office mee
between then-President George W
Dick Cheney
and ten members of the Nine
11 Commission, where they got to
basically anything they wanted a
what happened
leading up to those attacks.
CNN's Tom Foreman has more.
Yeah,
this really is a fascinating doc
when you look at it
secret until recently,
like a time capsule
that steps out and says,
what did they know
leading up to this attack?
And could that have utterly chan
everything that happened in the
since then?
Out of the confusion
following the nine 11 attack cam
Key questions
Did then-President George
W Bush and his team see it comin
and could they have stopped it?
Today, our nation saw evil,
the very worst of human nature.
The recently declassified report
from April 2004
shows him pushing back
firmly against that whole idea.
No one said there was a problem
domestically.
The threat was overseas.
That's what the report says.
Bush told members of the Nine
11 Commission
during an extraordinary question
and answer session
that lasted more than 3 hours.
About his reaction
to the attack
and his administration's
intelligence gathering.
The report,
which is not an official transcr
summarizes his explanation
We were aware
that bin Laden had sympathizers
in the United States prior to th
but there was no actionable
intelligence on such a threat.
Not one.
When a commissioner noted
there was intelligence
about specific attacks being pla
Bush repeated overseas.
We all understood
bin Laden's attempt
to strike the homeland.
What's more,
the report says,
when asked about intelligence
reports of domestic threats,
Bush replied,
If they came in and said,
We found a cell,
his Bush's action
would have been destroy it.
In another section,
a commissioner pushes the
then president
to explain his reaction
to an intelligence report
just a month before nine 11 enti
Bin Laden Determined to Strike i
The president said
since he was aware
that al Qaeda agents
were being tracked in America,
he had asked for it, that report
And it didn't say anything
about a specific attack.
In this meeting in the Oval Offi
he made clear that, yes,
they could see dots of informati
all over the place ahead of time
But even the best intelligence o
in the world couldn't
connect them into a constellatio
that warned of the specific even
in a way that they might be able
to prevent it in the end.
It is clear in this document
that Bush does say,
I had the responsibility,
but he clearly sees
that as something different
than having the blame.
Caitlin. Yeah.
And it's so rare to get a look i
something like this.
Clearly we haven't quite read. Y
For two decades.
Definitely worth a read.
Tom Foreman, thank you